des pistes cyclables provisoire depuis
le début du déconfinement plusieurs
villes françaises ont opté pour ces
aménagements
l'objectif désengorger les transports
publics mais aussi éviter le recours
massif à la voiture grenoble a choisi
cette alternative est déjà dans les
années 70 la ville faisait partie des
pionnières en matière d'aménagements
cyclables grenoble vient de se doter
officiellement d'une piste cyclable de 1
km 200 cela porte à cinq kilomètres la
zone réservée aux adeptes de la petite
reine
à cette époque en france les voies
cyclables sont très rares
pourtant le maire grenoblois hubert
dubedout les envisager déjà dans toutes
ces villes pour suivre ce que nous
appelons la rue en jour
hélas elle rejoindra une autre piste qui
ira vers le coeur de ville en passant
par derrière le stade de glace
l'aboutissement à grenoble de plusieurs
années de revendications dès le début
des années soixante dix les associations
de cyclistes réclamer plus de place et
de sécurité dans la ville
et l'on pouvait lire ou hasard des
banderoles et des pancartes de
revendications assez curieuse par
exemple assez d'autoroute à sept
parkings des vélos pas d'auto un slogan
en réaction à la politique toute auto
prônée par le président pompidou depuis
le début des années 60 et il résonnait
aussi dans d'autres villes françaises
exemple ici à paris en 1972
malgré la pression des usagers les
pistes cyclables se met timidement en
place en france dans les années soixante
dix ces aménagements coûte cher aux
municipalités et seules celles avec une
politique écologique forte sont prêtes à
investir strasbourg en faisait partie
en 1978 elle comptait aussi parmi les
villes pionnières
la communauté urbaine a donc voté un
budget considérable 27 millions de
francs à l'aménagement d'un véritable
réseau de pistes cyclables strasbourg
veut être en ce domaine agglomérations
pilotes strasbourg et grenoble sont
encore aujourd'hui des villes référence
en matière d'aménagements cyclables
d'autres villes françaises en font aussi
désormais une priorité et encore plus en
ces temps de crise sanitaire
[Musique]